invitée d'auditions publiques à six
jours maintenant du scrutin européen
nadine morano candidate sur la liste de
françois xavier bellamy bien sûr et
députée européenne sortante bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous je rappelle que
vous avez été également ministre de
nicolas sarkozy
merci donc d'être avec nous pour ce
rendez vous des chaînes parlementaires
du figaro et de l' agence france-presse
deux politiques dans un instant face à
vous nadine morano
le sénateur la république en marche
julien bargeton et le candidat sur la
liste du rassemblement national va les
rendre saint-just quatre journalistes
oriane mancini brigitte boucher et puis
tout de suite avec moi un vincent roux
du figaro et paul briat de la sp
messieurs bonsoir bonsoir merci
également d'être là nadine morano bien
sûr une question d'abord sur vincent
lambert qui est en état végétatif depuis
dix ans maintenant plus même la décision
du conseil d'état sur la fin des
traitements et a été mise en oeuvre
est ce que vous comprenez où est ce que
vous regrettez cette fin des traitements
qui est contestée on le sait par une
partie de sa famille notamment ses
parents c'est un sujet extrêmement
complexe et extrêmement douloureux comme
vous le savez moi j'ai été à
l'initiative de la loi sur la fin de vie
et le droit des malades avec gaëtan
gorce cette époque de la sphère de
vincent humbert
c'était un sujet là aussi qu'ils
appelaient la conscience de chacun
d'entre nous cette mission d'information
parlementaire d'ailleurs nous a permis
de nous faire tous évolué sur sur ce que
nous pensions aujourd'hui que pensez
vous aujourd'hui nous lançons
aujourd'hui autant vincent humbert lui
demander à mourir autant dans le cas qui
nous occupe aujourd'hui on ne connaît
pas quelle aurait été la volonté du
patient
sauf que sa femme rapporte qu'il ne
voulait pas subir ce qu'il est sauf que
sa femme rapporté que les parents disent
autre chose donc on est dans un contexte
de parole contre parole et est donc moi
je dis que quand il y a un doute tel que
celui là est bien la vie doit prévaloir
et
donc moi je sais que c'est quelque chose
de très compliqué très douloureux
j'essaie de m'imaginer si c'était un de
mes enfants comment je réagirais on
n'est pas dans une obstination
déraisonnable justement c'est une notion
qui apparaît dans le dans le texte de la
loi
je sais mais à partir du moment où il
est traumato lisez ou les handicapés est
ce que pour le coup la réflexion qui
doit nous amener dès lors qu'on n'a pas
la volonté personnelle de ce prix
exprimé clairement un hymne m2
directives anticipées
est ce que est ce que la justice peut
décider comme ça d' arrêter des soins
moi je moi je réponds que dans l'absence
de consentement personnel et quand il
n'y a pas accord et consensus à la fois
de la famille et du corps médical
je pense que la vie doit prévaloir alors
pourtant la mort à nous c'est jean
leonetti lui-même qui a dit que le
processus s'inscrivait parfaitement dans
la loi qui porte son nom
d'une part il dit jean leonetti qui est
chez les républicains naturellement il
dit on et dont nous sommes dans une
situation de prolongation artificielle
de la vie vous êtes donc en désaccord
avec lui vous savez sur cette question
c'est pas une question de clivage
politique
la preuve c'est que moi quand j'avais
demandé cette mission d'information
parlementaire je les fais guette encore
ce qui était un député socialiste
et là ça appelle à la conscience de
chacun alors évidemment j'entends que ça
peut être un acharnement thérapeutique
déraisonnable
personnellement je ne sais pas je n'ai
pas connaissance du dossier médical je
ne suis pas médecin
j'ai un avis qui est un avis comme tous
les citoyens français c'est-à-dire
extérieur et je connais évidemment cette
loi léonetti et donc elle s'inscrit dans
un processus possible mais dès lors
qu'il n'ya pas que les avis des médecins
s'impose à une partie de la famille
voilà moi je suis g
je suis très circonspect et je considère
que la vie doit doit prévaloir c'est pas
eu alors précisément est ce que vous
regrettez pas justement aujourd'hui
d'avoir en quelque sorte ouvert la boîte
de pandore avec cette mission
d'information vous aviez eu avec gaëtan
gorce et cette loi léonetti qui conduit
inévitablement aujourd'hui à l'arrêt des
soins pour vincent lambert c'est pas le
principe de précaution c'est pas le
principe de prévalence pour la vie qui
justement l'emportent
non parce que quand quand j'ai travaillé
sur cinq ans j'ai demandé cette mission
d'information parlementaire il se trouve
que gaëtan et moi avions été confrontés
dans nos vies personnelles c'est ce que
vous avez à ce sujet puisque mon père
avait fait un grave avc et ils étaient
lourdement handicapé et gaëtan lui était
confronté à un cancer en phase terminale
de son père et donc c'est vraiment des
réflexions que nous avions et en même
temps moi j'ai ça nous a fait beaucoup
changé tous beaucoup évolué sur ce qu'on
pense parce que ça va pas trop loin
maintenant on regarde ce que vous avez
dit la liberté ceux qui veulent arrêter
d'avis qu'il faut aller plus loin dans
une proposition de loi qui est en
préparation du côté de la république m'a
justement pour une euthanasie assumer et
là vous dites qu il ya dix ans avec un
personnage c'était là aujourd'hui on dit
quoi sur l'euthanasie est donnée de
faire le gers le geste létal
n'allons pas trop vite dans la carré il
s'agit de cas individuels
donc moi j'avais demandé à ce qu'il y
ait une commission qui puisse se réunir
d'un point de vue par exemple
départementale quand le sujet se pose
pour être au plus près de la situation
personnelle du patient notamment à ce
qu'il y ait un représentant de la
justice
on ne peut pas faire n'importe quoi sur
la vie de quelqu'un donc voilà j'ai
scellé il ya trop de considérations qui
peuvent entrer en ligne de compte comme
je voudrais toucher un héritage plus
vite que les autres qui sont attachés à
un acharnement thérapeutique
déraisonnable
qu'il n'accepte pas d'être confrontée au
départ dans leur croche
donc on est face à des décisions
individuelles on regarde la loi pour
l'instant on attend de son texte dans la
vie faut toujours évolué c'est pas le
sujet dans l'est dont moi je suis
toujours attaché à ce qu'on puisse
débattre et qu elle puisse évoluer là ce
que je constate
dans le cas d'espèce c'est qu'il ya un
désaccord au sein même de la famille et
qu'il n'y a pas eu de volonté clairement
exprimée ni même par des directives
anticipées
donc pour moi ça me pose un sujet et si
on passait comme ça ça veut dire que des
personnes qui sont lourdement handicapés
jusqu'où est ce qu on a calé la limite
de la dignité de la personne s'exprimer
il faudra garantir ça l'est également
pour garantir une disposition qui
garantissent cette protection pour le
personnel je pense pour les personnes
handicapées pour les personnes qui n'ont
pas donné d'accord je pense que encore
une fois me dire des cas individuels on
peut pas généraliser
d'accord on a compris votre position
tous les cas il est clair on va parler
bien sûr des élections européennes avec
le combat qui s'aiguisent surtout entre
les deux listes qui sont donnés en tête
a acquis la première place dimanche soir
est-ce que vous rejoignez nadine morano
le camp macro nist dans sa dénonciation
d'une nouvelle internationale de
l'extrême droite après le scandale russe
en autriche après le meeting on a vu
marine le pen mais toi salvini à milan
écoutez je l'aimais dos à dos à dos à
dos dos à dos ou le renvoyer dans un
ballet les maquereaux nist que vous les
appelez vous même le populisme et les
populistes de
marine le pen et de ses amis dont on
voit bien qu'ils sont des patriotes à
géométrie variable
parce que quand on quand on voit qu'on
est capable et ce qui a été démontré en
autriche d'aller brader des marchés
publics contre des financements
moi ça me choque profondément et c'est
bien que sebastian kurz et décider
d'élections anticipées est par ailleurs
en ce qui concerne monsieur macron je le
lui ai dit d'ailleurs personnellement je
n'ai jamais vu un président de la
république
divisez autant les les états membres sur
sur la scène européenne
rappelez vous de ce qu'il a dit de
polonais rappelez-vous nous sommes en
nous sommes avec des rapports
conflictuels avec avec l'allemagne nous
avons nous avons des rapports tendus au
bord de la crise diplomatique avec
l'italie
donc avec la hongrie n'en parlons pas
voilà quelqu'un qui nous joue du en même
temps parce que quand il a fait son clip
avec viktor orban
je lui ai dit à pont-à-mousson il est
venu lors de deux sons de ses
déplacements pour la commémoration du
centenaire de la première guerre
mondiale le 5 novembre dernier et je le
lui ai dit à table nous étions 25 élus
jeudi que ce ce clip me choqué
profondément que c'était pas un clip
d'information gouvernementale d'un clip
de propagande je n'ai demandé le prix il
était capable de notre dire certes mais
par ailleurs il m'a dit qu'à la fin de
ce déjeuner m'a dit mais c'est je
m'entends très bien les victoires en
bane au conseil européen
donc voilà quelqu'un qui non seulement
est dans le en même temps dans fait le
même temps cette double langage mais moi
je considère oui c'est ce que m'a dit
emmanuel macron et je considère que
honnêtement là nous sommes dans une
situation d'un espèce de match qu'on
voudrait nous imposer
entre marine le pen qui veut
déconstruire l'union européenne et
monsieur macron qui lui est dans une
attitude une arrogance et d'une division
incroyable sur la scène européenne
même françois hollande ne s'est même pas
comporté comme ça enfin je veux dire je
trouve ça très grave aujourd'hui il est
son comportement elle vous paraît marine
le pen
et pourtant quand on analyse les
programmes d'une part de votre liste
celle conduite par françois déry dégâts
ni d'autre part celle conduite par jour
nets bardella du rassemblement national
on va d des similarités des similitudes
sur la question des frontières par
exemple vous appelez à mettre en place
une double protection de nos frontières
c'est empreinte de l air par d'ex
européenne et une protection française
pour arrêter l'immigration de masse
et puis quand on lit programme du
rassemblement national rétablir des
contrôles aux frontières nationales en
sortant de la logique de la libre
circulation de schengen ou la différence
finalement entre vos vos deux listes
vous deux positions écoutez le front le
front national il faut bien comprendre
une chose à moi je les ai côtoyés au
parlement européen je sais exactement la
manière dont ils procèdent ils veulent
il faut être clair vous savez quand
marine le pen fait enlever du plateau de
tf1
quand elle était candidate élections
présidentielles le drapeau européen
pour elle il n'ya que le drapeau
français qui comptent y ajouter moi je
suis extrêmement patriotes mais je suis
je vis dans une région à trois
frontières et je me sens profondément
européenne je suis né dans l'union
européenne j'appartiens la première
génération qui n'a pas connu la guerre
et moi je rends grâce à ses performances
hors de l'union et toutes générations
ensuite confondu à l'issue qui ont voulu
transmettre en héritage
cette volonté d'être ensemble pour que
plus jamais ça norkom alors répondez pas
à la question qui sont les nôtres
mais j'ai dit à marine le pen je lui ai
dit faso parce que faut bien savoir que
là c'est brad des républicains rétablir
une double les frontières de la france
existe comme vous le savez elles
existent ces frontières bien nous sommes
dans un espace schengen sauf que la
surveillance des frontier des frontières
aujourd'hui ne se fait plus comme nous
étions avant l'espace schengen c'est à
dire que nous avions des postes
frontières fixes à cette époque là moi
dans ma région puisque j'ai 80 mille
personnes qui passent la frontière tous
les jours pour aller travailler de
l'autre côté ou luxembourg en belgique
ou en allemagne
on avait une heure et demie de queue
pour pouvoir passer de l'autre côté
maintenant tout cela n'existe plus mais
nous avons des contrôles avec ce qu'on
appelle la douane volante et des
coopérations internationales des chaque
côté de la frontière
ce qui est beaucoup plus efficace mais à
mon sens nous devons pouvoir rétablir
des contrôles quand il y a des problèmes
notamment de terrorisme les caps et
surtout je pense qu'il faut renforcer
les effectifs de cette douane volante
ils sont en demande il faut absolument
les renforcer par ailleurs les sur les
moyens de surveillance peuvent être
aussi faite de différentes manières vous
savez qu'aujourd'hui on peut avoir des
drones qui permettent de surveiller les
frontières parce que je suis vous dire
ce que dit marine le pen je lui expliqué
plusieurs fois quand elle dit il faut
remettre des postes frontières fixes
comme monsieur philippot qui était le
candidat tgv chez moi puisqu'il via les
candidats mais via paris simplement
pourquoi je dis ça parce que faire
croire qu'on va remettre des postes
frontières fixes d'abord pourquoi ça
n'est pas efficace quand il ya eu les
attentats à bruxelles il ya eu ils ont
remis en place des contrôles fixes des
points fixes s'en remettent évidemment
la bâtisse mais des points fixes
bon ces points fixes de contrôle en
revenant de bruxelles et comme tous ceux
qui connaissent les chemins
départementale moi je suis pas passée
par là j'ai pris les chemins
départementale pour rentrer plus vite
donc les points fixes de contrôle ne
sont pas ne sont pas ce qu'il faut faire
ce qu'il faut faire c'est vraiment d
avoir une douane volante efficace et
avec des coopérations internationales
beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus puissante
vraisemblablement vous allez être élu au
parlement réélu au parlement européen un
autre risque d'être réélu sur la liste
du rassemblement national c'est votre
ami thierry mariani est-ce que vous
travaillerez avec lui coûter ce que je
déplore chez thierry qui comme vous avez
raison de le direct annamites
gouvernement notamment
c'est quand je revois les propos qu'il a
tenus pendant des années voire des
décennies sur marine le pen je le laisse
assumer sa contradiction puisque revenir
sur la lys ou autres lieux qu'elle ait
du talent coûtait alors non j'ai dit
qu'elle avait un talent oratoire ce qui
est pas la même chose que lui trouver
les talents sur ses idées puisque je ne
partage pas ses idées elle a un talent
oratoire comme son père à talent
oratoire voilà mais en revanche sur les
idées je ne partage ni la vision de
marine le pen ni sac ont surtout il sera
député européen moi je ne sais pas si il
travaillera avec nous au regard des
idées qu'il défend maintenant qu'ils
sont plus les mêmes que ce que nous
avions avant c'est lui qui est parti
c'est pas moi donc je laisse face à ses
contradictions au garde de ce que tout
ce qu'il disait
s'agissant de la politique de marine le
pen il était reprenez ses propos c'est
vos journalistes en reprenait les propos
que disait que tenait thierry mariani
pendant des décennies on écoute la porte
n'est pas totalement fermée et vous
verrez bien avec lui mais lui
jean paul garraud jean paul garraud
thierry mariani et jean paul garraud ont
fait un choix de partir au front
national
bon ils assumeront leur choix ils
travailleront à la déconstruction nuit
européenne qui va à l'encontre de ce que
eux ont toujours défendu
ils ont enfin jeu quand on voit l'état
du royaume uni aujourd'hui l'instabilité
politique et l'impasse dans laquelle se
trouve le royaume uni je ne pense pas
que ni jean paul garraud ni thierry
mariani soit favorable à une sortie de
l'union européenne et soit favorable à
une sortie de l'euro
alors marine le pen c'est là c'est
pareil hein c'est ça dépend quel jour on
est mais quand elle vous dit qu'elle
veut plus sortir de l'euro mais quand
même temps et les pour la souveraineté
monétaire
la souveraineté monétaire pardon mais
elle veut revenir au franc
faux elle change peut-être de
vocabulaire mais en fait la volonté
politique est là même rencontré steve
bahamas est actuellement à paris
l'émissaire de trump je laisse à marine
le pen qui revendique son patriotisme et
qui par ailleurs se fait conseiller par
quelqu'un qui voudrait plutôt l'efs
l'affaiblissement de l'union européenne
moi si vous voulez je suis une vraie
patriote je considère que au regard de
la souveraineté de la france on n'a pas
cessé influencé par quelqu'un de
l'extérieur ça nous fait peur en gérance
russe dont on parle beaucoup en ce
moment on a su qu'ils avaient une
ingérence russe lors de la campagne des
présidentielles de la présidentielle de
aujourd'hui ça revient l affaire en
autriche avec cette tentative est ce que
ça vous fait peur moi je considère
concrètement que nous devons avoir des
relations avec la russie des sanctions
notamment à moi je suis pour la levée
des sanctions de l'union européenne
contre la russie qui nous a amenés à un
embargo russe qui pénalise lourdement
nos producteurs sur les tontons des
ingérences de la russie sur l'année
écoutez c'est à nous et à plutôt à
entretenir des relations bilatérales
beaucoup plus concrètes telles que nous
faisions d'ailleurs quand nicolas
sarkozy était président français ait
exercé la présidence de l'union
européenne nous avions des rapports à la
fois de ferme à la fois de discussion
est-ce qu'il faut laisser monsieur
poutine se tourner vers la chine ou vers
d'autres
je ne le crois pas donc on aa à à créer
de nouveaux liens avec la russie pour
qu'on ne tombe pas dans dans cette
espèce de relation qui n'est pas saine
ni pour l'union européenne et pour la
russie d'ailleurs encore une question
dans cette partie messieurs emmanuel
macron précisément sur emmanuel macron
un président qui sait qui s'implique
beaucoup dans cette campagne c'est quoi
cette bonne guerre c'est un problème
certain chez vous considère que c'est un
problème nicolas sarkozy l'avait fait la
même manière il ya des âneries son
interview dans les régions souvent il
rencontre la pqr presse quotidienne
régionale à l'elysée eh bien je pense
qu'elle fait en macro ni disons le très
concrètement parce que rappelez vous
quand même que monsieur macro nouveau
président en marche qui marche quand
même sur la tête
tout simplement parce que voilà plus de
20 ans que nous n'avions pas d'élections
européennes avec une liste nationale
nous avions des listes régionales tout
simplement parce que la volonté
politique était de rapprocher l'europe
des territoires eh bien monsieur lacroix
a voulu faire une liste nationale pour
tout simple pourquoi parce que il n'y a
pas d'accrochages territoriales il n'a
pas d'élus locaux dans les territoires
dans leur antre et non mais j'ai été des
dons mais ce pas une question de leur
donner mon cas personnel
moi j'ai été tête de liste dans la
région grand est ce alors mais non mais
il fait une liste nationale parce qu'il
n'a pas d'accroc gens et territoires
parce que la république en marche c'est
en partie virtuelle
il suffit de cliquer sur internet
pourraient être sympathisants de de la
république en argentine ou d'os élevé
nous nous avons un peu monde je pas vu
grand monde à venait dans les nôtres
c'est plein ça c'est clair mais nous
nous avons des fédérations structurer un
yach de tout le territoire français avec
les fédérations les républicains les
parlementaires les élus locaux et je
regrette qu'ils soient venus sur cette
liste nationale en présentant un
programme 18 jours avant l'échéance est
juste quant à lui alors il ya le feu
dans la maison macron dit vous vous
allez pouvoir parler dans un instant
avec le sénateur julien bargeton qui
fait son entrée sur le plateau avec
valeur en saint-just du rassemblement
national messieurs merci merci à vous
messieurs bonsoir installez-vous va le
temps pour moi de donner une question ou
une réaction d'un internaute du figaro
qui nous suit sur le figaro live et qui
réagit sur le chat c'est pierre qui nous
demandent que pensez vous de l'idée
d'une armée européenne
je sentais tellement d'autres allemands
contre totalement contre je pense que
avoir un fonds européen de défense et
mutualiser des moyens pour des
opérations sur des théâtres extérieurs
pourquoi pas d'ailleurs c'est déjà le
cas dans ces sur certains secteurs mais
avoir une armée européenne tout
simplement qui commande
voilà et donc qui commande on ne sait
pas et et comme au parlement européen je
vois que nous avons des divergences de
vues même au sort des propre groupe
politique avec certains pays entrés
il y à peu et qui viennent des pays de
l'est si si on laissait faire bien je
peux vous dire que je suis pas sûr qu'on
n'aurait pas des graves tensions avec la
russie donc non je ne suis pas pour
cette cause est très bien alors donc
emmanuel macron marine le pen en ont
pris pour leur grade lors de la première
partie de cette émission messieurs
bonsoir à nouveau julien bargeton on va
les rendre saint-just c'est à vous
monsieur le sénateur l'europe un rôle à
jouer en matière d'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes notamment pour le
droit des femmes
monsieur bellamy a refusé de condamner
la nouvelle législation très durs contre
l'avortement en alabama comment vous
sentez vous vous par rapport à ses
positions sur l'avortement ou d'autres
positions qui peut prendre en matière
sociétale
moi je crois que il faut pas caricaturer
parce que françois-xavier bellamy a dit
très clairement qu'il était pour une
politique de prévention pour que nous
ayons moins d'avortements en france
ce quelqu'un moi j'ai été ministre de la
famille et je vois bien que le nombre
des avortements depuis les années 90
chez les jeunes notamment continuent à
stagner en termes de nombre je crois
qu'il faut avoir une politique de
prévention
ensuite il est favorable à la liberté
des femmes plus d'accord mais moi je les
entends dû répondre à de plusieurs à
plusieurs reprises il est favorable et
j'en ai discuté avec lui il est
évidemment favorable à la liberté des
femmes
ci-après à titre personnel dans sa vie
personnelle
c'est peut-être s'il était confronté à
cette situation
peut-être qu'ils n'accepteraient pas
cette situation ça le regarde mais la
politique les positions sont des
positions qui ont des conséquences comme
des positions qui ont des conséquences
c'est lorsque vous prenez un engagement
de dire ben moi si je suis élu je vais
mettre en place une loi qui qui mettra à
mal la loi simone veil s'est absolument
pas le cas
il l'a dit il l'a répété donc n'allez
pas chercher des choses là où il y en a
pas c'est pas le sujet franchement aller
on s'ajuste marano moi je suis
heureux d'être là parce que je voudrais
qu'on puisse parler de sujets européens
est confronté vraiment nos points de vue
ce qui n'a pas été vraiment fait dans la
campagne jusqu'à maintenant il faut le
dire c'est un peu regrettable mais enfin
bon c'est comme ça et là je voulais vous
interrogez avoir votre point de vue par
rapport à des votes que votre groupe que
vous même que les parlementaires
européens français ont été mis au
parlement européen pendant la précédente
mandature parce que j'ai vu des
contradictions avec votre programme avec
thuel avec le programme de monsieur bel
et bien alors par exemple le 16 février
vous avez voté pour une résolution je
crois pour mettre à profit le potentiel
du traité de lisbonne afin de mettre en
place un système juridique et législatif
contraignant pour la répartition et la
réinstallation des migrants en europe et
vous avez même aggravé votre vote s'est
moqué par le 15 mai 2010 est pour le
soutien à la relocalisation des migrants
alors je parais eu assez mauvais pour la
politique française
ça me paraît contraire au programme de
monsieur bel ami à l'heure actuelle et
j'aurais voulu en tant que vos
explications sur ces votes que vous avez
monsieur valéry je vais vous dire une
chose c'est que moi je suis très attaché
à faire la clarté sur mes votes à
travers les explications de vote que je
publie à chaque séance à chaque fin de
séance plénière donc tous les français
qui nous écoutent qui veulent savoir ce
que j'ai voté et pourquoi j'ai voté de
telle manière peuvent aller sur le site
du parlement européen tapez nazis morano
ils trouveront toutes les explications
de vote en sup est ce que je vais pas
rentrer sur un tel un vol d'un tel un
vote parce que sinon sur les votes
je pense à des votes de nadine morano
par les hôtes du groupe des députés
français de retrouver mais c'est nadine
morano vous avez en face et moisson
fallait que je rentre dans les votes qui
ont été faits par le front national
notamment qui n'a pas
telle augmentation du budget de frontex
qui est qui qui qui est nécessaire pour
sécuriser nos frontières extérieures on
ne s'en sort pas donc telle est votre
vision quelle est la mienne
moi je vais vous dire une chose c'est
quelque chose qui nous différencie
vraiment d'abord comme vous le savez je
les dis surtout c'est tous les plateaux
et dans notre programme nous sommes très
clairs nous sommes absolument déterminés
à stopper l'immigration illégale qui est
sur d'autres territoires d'accord donc
pour ça nous contrairement à vous
puisque nous avons voté les moyens pour
renforcer l' agence frontex pour avoir
plus de dix mille gardes côtes pour
sécuriser nos frontières vous avez voté
contre mais je vous dire monsieur v
l'avant il ya bien il ya plus important
que ça on sait très bien que si on ne
fait rien s'agissant de l'afrique où moi
je suis membre de la délégation aux
charge des relations avec le parlement
panafricain ou au parlement européen et
donc moi ce que je dis c'est que tous
les bateaux qui viennent en provenance
de l'afrique ont vocation à repartir
vers le continent africain la solidarité
la solidarité non parce que monsieur
salvini lui il est pour la répartition
des migrants ce que moi je ne veux pas
il a il a refusé les bateaux tant mieux
il a refusé les bateaux qui arrivent en
italie mais lui ce qu'ils demandent
c'est la répartie sur les migrants moi
je ne veux pas la répartition une grotte
je veux l'expulsion des migrants arrivés
en situation irrégulière je veux que les
bateaux qui sont venus en provenance
d'afrique repart vers l'afrique parce
que la solidarité n'est pas uniquement
dû à l'union européenne tandis que lille
a une position plus radicale que celle
de monsieur salvini donc annoncer ça un
bien sûr parce que monsieur salvini lui
devrait partir les migrants dans les
pays l'union européenne moi je ne le
veux pas je veux que ceux qui veulent
venir sur le territoire européen en
venant écouter monsieur monsieur mes
cheveux longs et placer réagissions du
monsieur monsieur la rente saint-just je
voudrais que ceux qui nous écoutent pas
ce que vous allez dire j'ai voté sans
jamais moi ce que je souhaite c'est que
c'est les français qui nous écoutent ils
ont accès à des moyens d'information
on ne pouvait pas suivre joueurs
renvoyés sur votre chute morano point
commun c'est un morane au printemps
non non c'est non non excusez moi non
mais je suis bien en local le d'autres
éditions de recherche à moi non monsieur
nena l'est pas dans ce que nous ne
sommes pas je vous dis très concrètement
je suis candidate à cette élection
européenne
je suis pour la maîtrise des frontières
extérieures je suis pour que georges
jung auditionnant nous conditionnons
nous aide à l'afrique puisque nous
donnons 17 milliards d'euros chaque
année pour le développement de l'afrique
et je considère que le citoyen européen
n'a pas à payer deux fois une fois pour
le développement et une fois pour les
clandestins qui sont dans le sol et de
la victoire est en vue
cette fois donc je veut conditionner nos
z à l'anam écrits de retenir les
migrants à la maîtrise de capacités
africaines immigration parce que je vais
vous dire il ya un grand danger qui nous
guette parce que là la vague migratoire
qu'on a eu à connaître c'est pas grand
chose mais certains veulent inscrire
dans nos textes
la disposition de réfugiés climatiques
donc après l'asile politique l'asile
économique l'asile médical on va se
retrouver à voir un asile climatique
mais là je peux vous dire que là ça va
être porte ouverte et on ne va plus en
sortir c'est déjà compliqué maintenant
de s'en sortir et je suis contre eux
cela on peut changer aussi peut-être
l'anglais on peut débattre etc
vous savez que nous on souhaite refonder
schengen pour tout simplement à la fois
pouvoir accueillir ce qu'il ne peut ce
qu'ils le doivent
mais surtout aussi que l'europe assure
sa souveraineté sur ses frontières et
notamment en renforçant l'agencé frontex
avec dix mille personnes en plus et et
surtout éviter que c'est éviter et
éviter que ceux qui écrivent que ceux
qui contrôlent pas leurs frontières
continue à le faire parce qu'il faut
aussi dire qu'il ya des pays où d'un
financement préalablement commandées un
corps de fonctionnaires de 10000 à des
frontières aussi éloignée ce que les
pays frontaliers que les préfets qui
sont vingt ans le sait bien qu est-ce
qui ont séché les autres vous soutenez
monsieur montreux deiber pour prendre la
tête de la commission il est proche des
conservateurs autrichiens dont on a vu
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui enfin hier le
scandale dans le gouvernement autrichien
avec la proximité à la russie et qui
souhaitent délocaliser le siège de
strasbourg
est ce que ça vous pose une difficulté
de soutenir ce candidat conservateur qui
on ne parle pas un mot de français
monsieur le sénateur je vous signale que
la fin l'alliance
enfin ceci étant on sait pas parce qu'on
ne sait rien d'où vont siéger ou vont
siéger les députés en marche espère
sauver du programme hockey vous allez
faire un groupe progrès six mois pour
l'instant si vous voulez les personnes
avec les que monsieur macron lorsqu'il
est venu au parlement européen a reçu il
a reçu les députés du groupe alde et est
donc avec monsieur verhofstadt qui lui
est un des plus virulents a demandé à ce
que le siège du parlement européen soit
à bruxelles et non plus à strasbourg
dont il était gouverneur non mais vous
avez été clair ben moi je me suis aussi
moi je considère que le siège du
parlement européen est d'ailleurs ça
devrait être l'unanimité ce que ça n'est
ce que ce que 6 ou est-ce qu'ils parlent
discutent candidats européens dans dans
les faits les français sont pour
généralement les français sont pour
maintenir le siège au parlement européen
ça pourrait se discuter parce que comme
vous le savez on se réunit que quatre
jours par semaine par mois ou au
parlement européen mais moi je considère
que tu veux discuter vous le remettez en
cause à disputer pourquoi il les autres
pays le discute c'est parce qu'on ne se
réunit que quatre jours par mois mais
moi je considère être parce que la
réalité c'est que le siège européen à
vocation non pas être à bruxelles mais
que tous deux prêtés à rapatrier
bruxelles qui doit déménager à strass
mais bien sûr c'est ça la réalité parce
que la capitale européenne
et c'est dans notre programme et c'est
ce que nous avons dit avec leurs ventes
y est c'est que la capitale européenne
c'est strasbourg c'est strasbourg
conditions nommé ne fallait
l'éloignement est un problème quand même
derrière vous le vivez
d'ailleurs vous même et justement moi je
le vis au quotidien non mais vous avez
d'une part l'institution parlementaire
et donc l'institution parlementaire à
vocation est réuni sur un même site
imaginez vous si vous aviez l'assemblée
nationale qui siègent quatre jours à
paris et le reste du temps qui sera lyon
un moment vous vous direz ça serait bien
d'avoir tous au même endroit
et bien moi je considère et nous
considérons parce que c'était le départ
et c'est comme ça que ça a été créé que
le siège du parlement européen doit être
à strasbourg ceci étant il faut il faut
aider à voir plus de moyens à strasbourg
parce que vous avez des parlementaires
qui ont beaucoup de difficultés à
arriver à strasbourg parce que vous
n'avez pas de lignes internationales
comme vous pouvez en trouver à bruxelles
donc là il ya des moyens d'être pour que
strasbourg offre plus de possibilités
mais un art capital ou en faveur de
strasbourg c'est que c'est la ville de
la paix en europe puisque c'est elle qui
a été libéré par leclerc et que c'est là
où les derniers combats contre les nazis
ont eu lieu au faux pas ne faut pas
oublier ce mondial c'est aussi d'art
dans là ville mondiale de la tête c'est
aussi l'herbe
oui mais le centre mondial de la paix se
trouve à verdun au gabon oui c'était la
garde encore une fois sur des questions
peu de fond et je pense que là vous
allez voir vous expliquer sur le pacte
de marrakech madame morano
ils ont été tous a toujours en boucle un
le pacte de marrakech n'a jamais été
examinée au parlement européen c'est
donc vous avez tous ces cours vous avez
toujours vous même le pacte de marrakech
et oui je suis bien d'accord mais bon tu
as envie de rire mais laissez moi parler
mais chez moi
exposer ma question et vous me
critiquerait juste après donc le 18
avril 2018 tous les élus de votre groupe
sauf vous d'ailleurs et vous pourrez si
vous voulez bien nous expliquer cette
solitude et la contradiction que je vais
pointer ont voté pour une résolution en
faveur de la poursuite de l'élaboration
du pacte de marrakech donc vous vous
voter contre tous vos amis votre peau et
dans le programme de monsieur bellamy
s'est dénoncé au niveau européen le
pacte de marrakech proposition numéro 11
alors pourquoi n'avez vous pas voter
vous cette résolution est pourquoi il ya
telle une telle qu'on
addiction entre ce que vos amis et votre
groupe sur vous on fait dans la
précédente mandature et le programme de
monsieur belhadi alors d'abord pour être
très clair vis-à-vis de ceux qui nous
regardent et qui nous écoutent jamais le
pacte de marrakech en tant que tel en
tant que texte c'est parce que j'ai dit
mais moi je précise quand même qu'on a
été amené à être voté non mais a été à
elle n'a été votée au parlement européen
ni même dans les assemblées nationales
d'ailleurs voilà d'accord voilà donc il
y avait des résolutions moi je lis
toutes les résolutions
il y a des chapitres ou des paragraphes
qui peuvent me déplaire et donc j'ai
voté contre
après chacun a su mêler mes collègues
n'ont pas voté pour le pacte de
marrakech ça n'existe pas ils ont jamais
voulu une résolution immigrationniste un
nom mais je vous dis alors n'allez pas
caricaturer parce que je caricature pas
oui mais oui mais bon je vous je vous
explique et j'explique à ceux qui nous
regardent tous mes collègues
d'abord ne sont pas du tout des
immigrationniste ils sont sur la même
ligne que moi qui est de lutter contre
l'immigration illégale qui est de m qui
est que ceux qui veulent demander
l'asile chez nous le fassent dans des
hotspots sur le continent africain
lorsqu'ils viennent du continent
africain et pas sur le continent
européen
comme le veut la république en marche
non mais voilà donc c'est ce que nous
faisons depuis le départ en force en
nous les moyens de pression qu'on vous
dépouillent là ça a toujours été comme
ça en valeur surtout pendant les
périodes électorales c'est à dire de
l'est républicain l'ump avancera a
toujours prôné le répéter à lectra
repris notre programme là c'est ce qui
se passe dans cette campagne électorale
puisque je vois proposition numéro
dénoncée au niveau européen le pacte de
marrakech vous amis ont fait exactement
le contraire il ya un an en avril 2018
toile et on est en campagne
non mais nous sommes en campagne
électorale ça joue la corde et vous êtes
va être content parce que si vous dites
qu'on est que vous êtes des pouilles
aimons ce qui me concerne j'aime eu peur
pas de parler des questions migratoires
sans langue de bois et avec beaucoup de
vérité et en même temps vous êtes en
même temps rhabiller
vous devez être content parce que la
république en marche si le front
national aujourd'hui est aussi haut
et à chaque fois que le front national
ce que j'appelle pardon hein le parti du
rallye le rassemblement national celui
de quoi le ce que j'appelle le parti du
ras-le-bol
c'est à dire qu'en fait je rentre
szczyglo je rencontre beaucoup de gens
qui nous disent ah bah non mais moi je
vais voter le rassemblement national
pas parce que je crois en marine le pen
mais parce que la marée qu'il faut à
vous envoyer un avertissement monsieur
macro donc en fait les gens veulent
pourvu lors le jeu perd jamais c'est des
gens qui votent pour vous il votre
contre ne vote pas pour manouche pas
tout mélanger mépris j'ai pas trouvé moi
je vous les connaissez bien des yeux
pardon je ne maîtrise jamais vu mes
citoyens quels qu'ils soient mais au
contraire je les invite à regarder de
près votre programme puisque c'est ce
soir que vous êtes d'accord sur
l'immigration on est d'accord sur
l'immigration mais on devrait tous être
sur l'immigration on devrait tous être
d'accord sur l'immigration moi je ne
supporte pas l'immigration illégale et
et j'ai pas besoin d'être au front
national ou de renier ce que je pense
parce que nous on n'a pas le droit de
parler d'immigration est ce que
l'immigration et a été éteint une
problématique qui doit être qui doit
être réservé au front national je ne
crois pas ce sort que j ai laissé entrer
tout le monde pendant ses 50 ans
rapporte c'est une chose est sûre d'une
chose est sûre la famille le pen
prospèrent sur la misère des français
depuis des années sans rien proposer
sans rien proposer de se rapprocher des
choses de choses crédible et ça s'est vu
d'ailleurs dans la présidentielle de
le manque de crédibilité de madame le
pen a été évidemment on n'en fera pas on
a le sentiment que je la com - crédit on
a un sentiment que la que là que votre
liste nommé pas l'écologie en priorité
contrairement là note vous savez que
nous avons un certain nombre de
propositions de la banque européenne du
climat ou la taxation du kérosène ou
encore ne pas ouvrir des négociations
commerciales avec les états unis tant
que l'accord de paris bien il ne leur
met pas en oeuvre
quelles sont vos propositions en matière
de transition écologique
moi vous savez je pense que l'écologie
et se doit doit se vivre au quotidien
sans qu'on culpabilise en permanence et
sans confiance en clair mal jeudi
une proposition d'accord mais je dois
quand même de faire une phrase bien sûr
bon sens qu'on taxe aussi les gens moi
j'ai j'appartiens à la commission
industrie au parlement européen
nous avons pris beaucoup de mesures
notamment sur l'efficacité énergétique
des bâtiments
je crois que nous devons aider aussi et
même si on considère que c'est pas
quelles sont vos propositions là pour
l'avenir puis là vous parlez de ce que
vous avez fait comme l'eurodéputée
sortante
mais quels sont vos questions ou sepa
frappant ce qu'il ya sur l'écologie
c'est pas frappant messi enfin je vais
vous dire c'est pas frappant non plus
quand vous parlez des agriculteurs que
monsieur macron écrit sa grande lettre
là à tous les citoyens européens en
ayant passé 14 heures au salon de
l'agriculture
alors que le budget du parlement
européen le plongeur portant des noms
mais c'est parce que ses qualités de la
présidence le sénateur non monsieur non
parce que l'environnement c'est aussi
l'agriculture de sur le souhait
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur monsieur
le sénateur je voudrais simplement vous
dire que quand j'ai vu cette tribune
rédigée par monsieur macron où il n'y a
pas un mot sur l'agriculture à tous les
citoyens quand bpa sur vos propositions
du l'écologie n'est si sur l'écologie
même si c'est pas le coeur de notre
sujet nous le coeur de notre sujet parce
que l'écologie le coeur de l'écologie de
ma tête dans toute la mesure de la
semaine et c'est comme au coeur du dakar
de laurent et vous savez ça doit être
dans toutes nos politiques dans l'es10
quotidienne parce que quand je voit
l'hypocrisie qui consiste à dire s'il
faut changer de véhicule et que tous les
véhicules diesel vous savez où ils
partent les véhicules diesel mais via
véhicules diesel monsieur le sénateur
pour l'instant à free et quand on fait
croire que la police passion opposition
à la critique en commission que la
pollution ne traverse pas la
méditerranée ça me rassure des
formations des illustrations qui a pas
de propos n'a rien que la source de tous
les problèmes ne se ressemblent pas ce
reproche
voilà en tous les cas merci merci enfin
c'est terminé voilà c'est bien voilà je
vous aviez encore d'autres votations
strady la nouvelle zélande badara bèye
non non non merci encore monsieur voit
la dernière partie l'audition publique
maintenant avec lauriane mancini abrégée
de boucher qui font la rentrée sur ce
plateau
bonsoir en question d'une internautes du
figaro nadine morano qui vous elle
s'appelle marc l'année elle s'enquiert
de vos relations avec nicolas sarkozy
aujourd'hui nicolas sarkozy qu'on
n'entend pas pendant la campagne
non non vous lasser c'est pas que ça me
laisse sans voix c'est parce que moi je
les régulièrement au téléphone et je
sais qu'il suit de très près cette cette
campagne je vous rappelle que nicolas
sarkozy est adhérente sa famille
politique j'ai pas depuis l'âge de 18 ou
20 ans qu'il n'y a jamais fait défaut
qu'il est toujours adhérent des
républicains et que quand il faudra
aller voter même si à 34 bulletin sur la
table il se trompera pas un il mettra le
bulletin mais république faire mieux
mais il peut appeler on appelle françois
hollande après françois hollande la
faille a dit qu'il voterait pour
l'aliment et violette rapport
des gens il n'ya pas longtemps où il a
dit qu'il suivait de très près ces
travaux ça a été rendu public dans la
presse donc
après entretien vous parle d'un appel à
voter bellamy ou l'appeler puis vous
vous posez des questions
il reste une semaine donc je ne sais pas
s'il prendra une position faisant ses
déclarations et mais quand même je
souhaite coûte et moi je suis attaché à
respecter cette liberté donc je vois là
pour lui donner des ordres s'il le fait
c'est bien s'il ne fait pas tout le
monde sait qu'il faudra pour nous et
donc sa part jugé ça donnera un petit
coup de pouce à la vitesse n'est pas
elle qui participera à un meeting parce
que non parce que je pense que il a fait
le choix de se retirer de la politique
active
mais quand même en même temps il s'y
intéresse parce qu'il nous reçoit très
régulièrement et que tout moi et moi je
suis à même de vous dire sur ce bateau
qui votera pour nous voilà est il donc
ça c'est plus est plus fort que tout 13%
des français xavier bellamy qui plafonne
dans les sondages après une dynamique en
début de campagne
est ce que vous y êtes victime de la du
vote utile des électeurs de centre droit
qui se disent que finalement il vaut
mieux voter pour emmanuel macron d'abord
il reste une semaine je crois que c'est
d'un point de vue médiatique on essaye
d'en fermer se débattent d'ailleurs ce
débat il avait eu lieu
enfin on est on est dans un débat
escamoté tout simplement parce qu
emmanuel macron a souhaité l'asphyxié
nous sommes dans une crise et gilet
jaune qui dure de plus depuis six mois
où on a été dans grand débat dans le
grand blabla et s'asphyxie totalement la
campagne européenne mais c'était une
volonté
quand vous avez la république en marche
qui ne présente son programme de 18
jours avant les élections européennes
ça peut quand même poser question alors
oui je sens qu'on veut imposer aux
français le match la troisième manche
des élections présidentielles seillière
va vous n'avez pas le choix et vous
aurez tous ses bulletins de vote ya un
seul jour un seul tour c'est jours la
fête des mères mais il faudrait que vous
soyez condamné à voter pour emmanuel
macron parce que sinon vous elle va voir
et vous allez avoir le rassemblement
national devant emmanuel malaise
parce que vous proposez pas
d'alternative suffisante est ce que vous
faites pas envie peut-être au milieu de
ce match entre emmanuel macron et marine
le pen est ce que finalement il ya plus
d espace politique pour les républiques
et aujourd'hui d'abord vous fondée
uniquement sur des sondages
et franchement d'abord quand je vois la
différence de résultats dans certains
sondages qui passe de 15 à 11
et on se dit mais qu'est ce que c'est
que ces sondages
moi je trouve que ces sondages c'est
même dangereux c'est ça une volonté
d'influencé
ce que pensent les gens et de dire on va
vous savez c'est la tenda je sais pas
mais je m'interroge sur le fait d'avoir
des sondages à proximité des échéances
et des faiblesses pour vous mais je dis
pas fait que news
mais yahia sans doute sur l'élection
c'est sans doute une volonté alors
renforcé par part par les médias
évidemment sans que le débat puisse
vraiment voir lieux emmanuel macron ne
veux pas que ce débat ait lieu
il ne veut pas parce que lui sur des
lits objet d un allié objectif c'est
marine le pen lui ce qu'il veut c'est se
retrouver face à marine le pen
or il veut pas se retrouver derrière il
veut se retrouver devant mais pas
derrière mais il veut se retrouver avec
marine le pen parce que lui veut
personne au milieu
ben moi je me pose des questions sur le
sens que peu à voir emmanuel macron de
la démocratie ah oui franchement mais
bien sûr où on vient 34 liste il n'y a
pas de problème démocratique mais c'est
finalement c'est une volonté d'y de
diluer ce débat vous je vous rappelle
que le plafond pour être remboursés a
été descendu de rapport à 3% qu'il était
à 5 % aujourd'hui voilà pourquoi vous
avez une multitude de listes qui sont 12
ou moins crédibles on voit bien que
certaines n'arrivent même pas à avoir
des bulletins de vote ni même d'
affiches ni de profession de foi et donc
on est dans une dans une élection à la
fois asphyxié par le grand débat qui a
voulu monsieur remettront à la fois
dilué par le nombre de listes que les
français se dit mais qu'est ce que c'est
que ces listes alors ferait bien bas
saison le fait qu'il en effet une
échéance nationale vous avez maintenant
un bulletin de vote avec 79 mo / sur le
bulletin de vote
alors qu'avant on avait des scrutins
régionaux et les gens se dit ah bah
tiens ça c'est des gens que je connais
ils sont mon territoire c'est des élus
proches de nous maintenant lui et il
nous a fait une liste nationale et on
voit qu'il se prend un petit peu les
pieds dans le tapis parce que marseille
va perdre foot et j'en sais rien
ce que je veux c'est appelé ceux qui
nous regardent aller voter pour la liste
les républicains mais ce que la droite
trocadéro à l'ap a atteint son plafond
de verre vous reprenez vous reprenez
l'expression d'edouard philippe l
expression des doors fil d'arrivée après
préciser parce qu'on a l'impression que
c'est la vôtre donc moi je suis parce
que c'est la droite trocadéro la leyre
par interdire aux cadets la droite
trocadéro que je connais et à laquelle
j'ai participé
c'est quand nicolas sarkozy au cours de
la campagne présidentielle a fait son
grand discours au trocadéro le 1er mai
et où j'ai eu l'honneur de prendre la
parole au trocadéro devant je sais plus
combien de sang de milliers de personnes
y avait j'ai eu beaucoup d'émotions et
moins de françois fillon à la dernière
élection elle faisait part moi je suis
une femme de droite je le revendique
j'appartiens à la droite gaulliste
social je le revendique que j'ai jamais
eu honte d'appartenir à cette à cette
droite et je pense que les voir philippe
n'est pas de droite
il a commencé chez rocard il est
maintenant chez emmanuel macron ça va
bien et si vous voulez est-ce que vous
opposez la droite trocadéro à la droite
juppé balado enfin la droite gp moi j'ai
connu alain juppé très à droite quand il
est tant mieux enfin dans les années 90
lorsque ils défendent une politique
migratoire ferme et quand je vois ce qui
est devenu alain juppé maintenant dont
ses principaux collaborateurs sont chez
emmanuel macron donc voilà chacun peut
évoluer dans la vie moi j'ai une colonne
vertébrale gg colonne vertébrale j'ai
des convictions fortes et profondes et
je ne change pas d'avis toutes les deux
minutes en fonction des circonstances
donc moi je dis qu'il faut lutter contre
l'immigration illégale la politique
économique de monsieur macro est
désastreuse
voilà pourquoi le rassemblement national
semble flirter avec des scores aussi
port parce que ce soit les retraités que
ce soit les classes moyennes que ce soit
la politique migratoire qu'ont subies
dans notre pays les gens en ont ras le
bol c'est pour ça que je dis que c'est
le parti
du ras-le-bol mais c'est pas le parti de
la solution parce que le parti de la
solution c'est les républicains la
droite républicaine
le centre uni avec hervé morin et je
crois que nous avons une vraie et les
mois sur edouard philippe edouard
philippe il choisit quand même c'est les
villes dans lesquelles il fait campagne
pour la liste renaissance il était à
ranger chez christophe béchu il est à
vesoul chez alain chrétien que des
maires de droite qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous est ce que vous craignez qui
rallie à lui ses élus locaux de droite
et pousser ces mères de décider ce
qu'ils veulent faire
moi je constate que arnaud robinet maire
de reims
je constate que monsieur mou dingue
maire de toulouse que christian estrosi
maire de nice qui conque on donnait
comme mâcon compatibles sont tous
revenus à la maison
1 c'est à dire qu'ils sont touchés les
républicains soutiennent la liste
françois xavier mais l'ami et se laisse
pas avoir par des promesses qui serait
faite par en marche pour les prochaines
quand il dit que la recomposition du
paysage n'est pas terminée et que dire
oui mais là encore on n'a pas quand on
si la poutre sur laquelle on est assis
en général on termine mal la charpente
et après bezos edward physique on est
mal barrés un jour il disparaît
terminera comment alors par exemple
c'est par exemple si la liste macro nist
arrive en deuxième position dimanche
comment il va terminer doit fédérer je
suis votre logique ou votre raisonnement
là peut-être nadine morano ce moment là
je ne peux pas faire de projections de
la comète mais je pensais que le prix le
président à un public si il se trouve
confronté à se retrouver deuxième voire
en troisième position derrière les
républicains parce que apporter une
vraie
vrai j -ph l emmanuel macron ça veut
dire de le mettre en troisième position
pour dire non à la fois sa politique
désastreuse et non à l'arrogance qu'il a
sur la scène européenne
l'assaut aurait un sens ça voudrait dire
ou alors parce que dans l macron à mon
avis n'aurait pas d'autre choix
mais que de faire un remaniement
gouvernemental et de changer de cap
politique la ministre alors ça nous
avons pensé c'est ça la vraie belle mois
déjà si vous voulez les traîtres moi
j'ai du mal hein donc nommer un premier
ministre qui au départ pendant la
campagne législative vient prendre le
déjeuner avec nous et le dessert chez
emmanuel macron j'ai un peu de mal je
vous le dis donc moi quand on tape sur
emmanuel macron comme il l'a fait
d'ailleurs pendant la campagne de juppé
ou il épie que pendre de manuel macron
poussoir pour se retrouver son premier
ministre si vous voulez moi d des
convictions avec une colonne vertébrale
qui part en serre trop pour à nouveau
trahi et trahir emmanuel macron et
fonder un mouvement à droite qui
pourrait être une alternative aux
républicains non mais monsieur edouard
philippe n'est pas de droite quand on
est de droite
prenez ce n'est pas lui arracher ses
convictions donc le talent et être de
droite ça veut dire réduire la dépense
publique
être de droite ça veut dire respecter
les retraités et ne pas augmenter la cg
et en même temps désindexer les
retraites ce que personne n'a jamais
fait depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
personne n'a fait ça donc c'est ça c'est
pas notre pays alors quand ça c'est une
politique de gauche je connais retraités
y est votre pour emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui et 20 5% des électeurs de
françois fillon
ces sondages et les sondages les études
d'opinion oui mais ses études de piano
chez moi j'ai la pression je préfère le
résultat des ions aux études d'opinion
alors on verra ça dimanche alors j'ai
encore deux personnalités à vous
soumettre de l'apd droite jean-pierre
raffarin je me souviens vous aviez dense
et d'une façon endiablé je me souviens à
nice lors d'un campus de l'ump vous
souvenez un sens bien rappeur alors
aujourd'hui
1 vous avec lui que ça c'est bien
dommage parce qu'il ya des images fortes
avaient montré cette proximité est
aujourd'hui ce que vous le traitez de
traite puisqu'il soutient la liste menée
par madame l'oiseau parce que lui aussi
est un traître
nous avons en partage l'amour de johnny
hallyday je suis à des fins politiques
ça nous finissons en revanche j'aurais
préféré que vous me citiez cette vidéo
que j'ai posté régulièrement sur les
réseaux sociaux où monsieur raffarin en
appelés à voter pour nadine morano aux
dernières élections à tout va et alors
quand il dit je sais où j'habite
j'habite rue du fait jusqu'à sarkozy
machin truc je dis simplement que
peut-être il savait où la mi mai il a
perdu le gps et sa boussole pour
gravière et c'est tant pis mais c'est
vraiment dommage deuxième personnage
c'est xavier bertrand alors qu'ils ont
dit en piste pour 2022 vous suivez bien
sur lui alors il n'a pas cédé aux
sirènes macro nist communauté ils vont
très bien par était le chef de l'état
qu'il n'ira pas matignon si on lui
demande qu'est ce que vous pensez de son
positionnement il n'est plus à l air il
n'est pas ma chronique et il vise 2022
il est tout seul quand on est tout seul
on ne fait pas grand chose voilà moi les
parcours individuels c'est comme jean
christophe lagarde qui est tout seul il
y à 2 % dans les sondages
bon quand on est tout seul on représente
en rien il n'y a pas qu'à bien ds xl
ibérique rend bête tout seul non j'ai je
lui ai dit c'est pour moi c'est
incompréhensible que et bertrand soit
partie de notre famille politique on
peut appartenir à droite justement futur
alors les gens populaires
si si je regarde les sondages alain
juppé devait être présent la république
donc puisque le service 2022 il faut
qu'il revienne dans votre famille
politique ou de toute façon jerhinat
plus après moi je n'ai rien à lui dire
chacun est responsable surtout à son âge
je suis pas sa mère donc il fait ce
qu'il veut simplement jour sexy danger
pour vous pour dominer
constate que les parcours individuels et
ça nicolas sarkozy je peux vous dire que
du temps du rpr
lui aussi a connu certaines difficultés
tu sors du temps du rpr mais n'a jamais
n'a jamais quitté sa famille politique
les digues les parcours individuels
enfin ne mène nulle part
vous dites moi dans la série des gens
que vous qualifier de traîtres en tout
cas des anciens première fois que je le
dis vous aurez pas un scoop avec 55 58
et qui maintenant sont au gouvernement
il ya bruno le maire qui disait hier
dans le journal du dimanche
pourquoi je vais vous lire sa phrase
après vos commentaires
la prétendue unité des républicains
n'est que de façade sitôt les élections
passées la guerre des chefs reprendra de
plus belle chassez le naturel à la
droite il reviendra au galop
qu'est ce que vous lui dis là je sais
pas quel est son naturel elle lui
puisqu'il a fait 2 % à la primaire de la
droite il a dit tout au long de cette
primaire rappelez vous il avait mille
propositions là il nous avait sorti un
truc
il a fait cette primaire en expliquant
dans toutes les réunions qu'il fallait
baisser la cg est donc maintenant le
ministre de l'économie c'est fort de la
part de monsieur macro ans de faire
faire à quelqu'un le contraire de ce
qu'il pense moi je dis que franchement
et donc il met en oeuvre
l'augmentation la cg alors après le
matin je ne sais pas comment il fait
pour se regarder dans la glace parce que
être à ce point là dans la contradiction
de ses convictions ça veut dire qu'il
n'a pas du tout de convictions
politiques
et moi j'ai pas d'admiration pour les
gens comme ça est ce que laurent
wauquiez fait l'unité de votre famille
politique
laurent wauquiez d'abord il a été élu au
suffrage de nos débuts de nos militants
et il est il n'a pas été nommé comme le
secrétaire général d'and marche lui il a
été élu par nos militants à hauteur de
74% des suffrages donc il est un
président élu et bien élu il est vrai
par ailleurs je constate que c'est lui
qui a fait ce choix de françois xavier
lamy et que le trio de tête qui était
son idée de rassembler
différentes sensibilités de la droite
avec arnaud danjean a des qualités c'est
vrai proche de valérie pécresse et avec
arnaud danjean plutôt de la ligne alain
juppé c'est pas une unité de façade
c'est un trio qui a très bien marché et
qui est sur le terrain en permanence et
moi je peux vous dire que pour avoir pu
être participer au meeting de paris où
madame pécresse est venue s'exprimer ou
gérard larcher président du sénat
étaient présents aussi je peux vous dire
que cette unité
elle est dans le rassemblement et ça
fait bien longtemps qu'on n'avait pas
vécu ça et moi je vais j'y vais pas est
ce que finalement on savait déjà que des
amis n'a rallié va faire l'unité que
leurs ancêtres et dire que c'est laurent
wauquiez qu'a construit ce rassemblement
et donc il faut quand même comprendre ça
c'est lui qui l'a construit puisque
c'est lui qui a choisi ce trio tête et
parce que c'est lui qui a choisi
françois faisait bellamy donc c'est lui
qui ramène tout le monde à l'année
longue série qui sera contacts de votre
corps le 26 mai elle a écouté mais c'est
un sport collectif
on en est tous comptables que tout le
monde fasse le boulot sur le terrain et
même s'il fait moins que les 20 % la
présidentielle mais il sera pas et ne
devra pas passer leur bac éco pourquoi
vous comparez une présidentielle et les
élections européennes vous confirmez
vous situer par rapport aux dernières
élections mais pas du tout l'élection
présidentielle c'est une élection
présidentielle élections européennes
d'abord le taux de participation n'est
pas du tout même et donc si vous
comparez l'élection européenne à une
autre élection européenne pourquoi pas
moi j'ai fait 22 72 % dans le grand est
quand j'étais tête de liste bon et quand
nous étions au pouvoir avec nicolas
sarkozy nous avions fait + 29 % ce qui
est loin du résultat de monsieur macron
qui lui est aujourd'hui au pouvoir
donc on voit bien que le présent la
république déçoit vous posiez france et
13 % aujourd'hui pour bellamy doigt sur
l'un d'eux lors de la primaire de sa
fille mais non mais non mais ça n'a rien
à voir avec la primaire je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la vie politique ce qui
se passe dans notre pays depuis deux ans
avec la crise des gilets jaunes la case
tous les samedis et de nature à apporter
une forme de désespérance chez nos
compatriotes notamment vis-à-vis de la
politique et je trouve ça triste et
celui qui en est aussi responsable c'est
emmanuel macron parce qu'il n'est pas
capable de résoudre la crise d
je pense d'ailleurs qu'il avait on paye
son inexpérience voilà quelqu'un qui
était peut-être un jeune président mais
qui n'avait pas d'expérience et
aujourd'hui on paye sa très chère et
nous sommes par ailleurs très isolé sur
la scène européenne
et ce qui nous occupe vous aurez
aujourd'hui c'est la voix de la france
dans l'union européenne
il reste moins de deux minutes peut-être
une dernière question sûrement fait
webber vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure
c'est le candidat que vous soutenez à la
commission européenne si michel barnier
fait acte de candidature qui
soutiendraient vous écouter on a vous
savez comment fonctionne le dispositif
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement doivent
respecter doivent tenir compte des
résultats électoraux dans les 28 pays le
dernier français est fluctuant votre
liste il a pas de là mais ok mais chez
monsieur barnier n'a pas été candidat
sur sur ces élections européennes il est
en charge du break site je pense que
d'ailleurs il va continuer à suivre
parce que vous avez vu que nous ne
sommes pas sortis aujourd'hui et que la
question quoi qu'il arrive seulement de
prévert voilà la réponse est claire
dernière question du deuxième volet du
procès balkaniques et a commencé à être
examiné aujourd'hui patrick balkany donc
après la fraude fiscale et le
blanchiment il ya la corruption est ce
qui fait du mal à la droite
moi je ce soit quelqu'un de la famille
politique ou que ce soit monsieur
cahuzac ou d'autres je n'ai jamais
commenter une procédure judiciaire
jamais tout simplement parce que je suis
attachée à la présomption d'innocence
monsieur balkany n'est pas condamné et
donc la procédure judiciaire est en
cours
monsieur balkany a fait un travail
remarquable dans sa commune de levallois
perret je lisais la presse de ce matin
et beaucoup d'habitants le confie le
disais je
mais je les constate également
propos des juges du procureur mais les
propos des juges et des procureurs pour
l'instant est ce qu'il est jugé
est ce qu'il est jugé non donc ça n'en
savait rien mais il est pas qu'on allait
encore bien sûr que non y'a des
acquisitions des réquisitions et moi je
n'ai rien à dire la procédure est en
cours
je sais juste que j'ai de l'amitié pour
patrick balkany et son épouse dans le
constat est que ça moi je ne connais pas
son dossier fiscal je sais juste qu'il a
réussi à faire pour sa commune qui est
remarquable et donc cette amitié pour
moi le perdure merci à vous merci à vous
merci mesdames a très vite